à la faveur de l'automne
7 vous aimez dans un deux trois quatre
colonnes de vieillards mélodies quant à
vue je donne pas tout parce que je
voudrais pas te faire d'ombré je vais
rester à ma place d'intervieweuse déjà
c'est bon de te voir et de t'entendre en
live
merci d'être là bas nous aussi on est
vraiment ravi de t'avoir alors tu avions
tu as fait un petit décor qui est assez
raccord avec ce que tu nous as fait
pendant le confinement tu nous a régalés
l'âme tous les jours avec des reprises
absolument magnifique dont tu as fait ça
sur les réseaux sociaux et de fil en
aiguille c'est devenu carrément un
projet d'album qui s'appelle lap dance
échelle raconte nous un peu la genèse de
cette aventure
et bah écoute mon continent j'ai eu
envie de me faire plaisir en travaillant
des chansons que j'adore des chansons
d'artistes qui me donne envie de faire
ce métier là si on a tous des livres
qu'on met de côté des fois et on se dit
je les lirai les prochaines vacances je
dirais quand j'aurai tant pis tu les lis
jamais et quand confinement est arrivé
je me suis pas c'est quoi les chansons
que j'ai toujours rêvé de reprendre tu
voies pour essayer d'inscrire des
progressions d'accords essayer de les
balancer sur internet les gens
commencent à s'enregistrer par dessus
donc ça a créé des duos virtuels
quelqu'un ma vie faisant un album on a
fait un croche funding et puis dans
l'idée d'en faire profiter les autres
aussi c'est important pour moi dans huit
et cinq personnes qui sont distingués
sur la partie vidéo du projet à figurer
sur l'album avec moi ouais ça je suis
vraiment content de ça c'est ce que tu
raconte aussi ce qui a été le plus dur
pour toi dans toute ta carrière de
médecin ça a été le la première étape le
premier disque donc c'est leur permettre
aussi de faire ça c'est presque une
question de karma de laisser ouverte la
porte derrière toi maintenant que toi tu
es là tu fais monter les autres mais
c'est clair en fait moi j'ai toujours
entendu dire que ce métier j'étais une
histoire de rencontres et j'y crois
vraiment les collègues avec qui on va
partager un peu de musique toute heure
on avait deux jolis souvenirs en commun
parce que on a commencé au même endroit
appareil à 20 ans j'ai fait le chapeau
dans les endroits où ils ont fait le
chapeau aussi
et à l'époque c'était ça tu joué pendant
les happy hours parce que dans les bars
c'est là que les mecs de mon jeu parce
qu'il a personne et puis c'est un jour
comme ça je fais mon set le bar est
désert j'ai voir un mec
je tends mon chapeau aux gars comme ça
il me dit j'ai pas de moyenne je suis
grattée une clope à l'ancienne et puis
on commence à parler et me dit moi si tu
veux j'ai un petit filet etc
et puis de fil en aiguille c'est comme
ça que j'ai eu certes je me suis
retrouvé à faire mon premier disque mais
si je n'ai pas croisé ce mec dieu seul
sait tu vois ce que ce que ben voilà ce
qui se serait passé derrière et je
trouve ça important dans dans une vie de
musiciens musiciennes tu puisse croiser
cette personne n'en fait ici on est dans
cet endroit qui s'appelle zone i c'est
une sorte d'utopie culturel en plein
milieu de la campagne
ça pourrait être quoi ton utopie à toi
tu étais avoir un lieu comme ça puis
installé en famille se serait ce serait
fou parce que finalement quand habite en
ville entre guillemets ce qui est le
plus cher si le temps et les mètres
carrés et moi ce que j'aime dans ce
genre de lieu
eh ben c'est le genre de lieu où t'as
pas envie de partir en vacances ou en
week-end avec ta famille justement ce
qu'on a réussi à faire pendant le
confinement un truc un peu en dehors du
temps tu vas une pièce comme ça pour moi
c'est je me dit bon voilà le studio je
vais le mettre sur le maître la stib
quoi voilà c est une utopie comme ça où
tu puis tu peux avoir une chambre d'amis
accueillir des amis à voir en studio
faire un disque où c'est simple ou en
battant vie de tant de faire à manger
tue parce que finalement tout ça surtout
des musiques acoustiques le folk le
blues c'est à des musiques de vie en
fait c'était très soluble dans la vie
quotidienne exactement exactement
bon bah c'est super je vais te laisser
continuer à répéter un peu et a trouvé
l'inspiration pour ce soir alors à tout
à l'heure tu es peut tout faire